はい ではよろしくお願いいたします
はい 始まります で アーセーは心の裏なんですね
それまた裏があるという
裏の裏 裏の裏 表やと思ったら違うんですね
心にはさらに深いレベルの働きもあります
で なんとかちょっと人がすごく怒っているいても
じーっとその人は何日間
何週間 何ヶ月間 その人のことをじーっと調べていると
まあそっち怒ってるんだけど
本心は優しい人だというふうに発見できるかも
この裏の裏はもうそんなとこじゃない
もう発見できない これは機能しない潜伏する煩悩の種なのです
潜伏しているんです わからないんです
ブッダにしか発見できない人の心の暗闇の中に隠れている煩悩なのです
これが発見できるのはたったブッダ一人だけなんです
前のアーセーというところは
まあなんとなくいっぱいテキストもありますから
いろいろ実例いっぱいもありますからね
なんとなくできるんだけど
これは無理なんです これがアヌセーと言うんです
これ睡眠煩悩なんですね
冬眠中の煩悩は潜在煩悩というね
で 我々の煩悩が冬眠中です
冬眠中だから別にまあ機能しないんですよ
これがアヌセーというんですね
だからアーセーといえば
もうもう頼りになって土台にしている
アヌセーっていうのはそれ下にあるものなんです
で  7つあります  1番目はカーマーラーガーアヌセー
煩悩として同じものです
リストは同じです カーマーラーガーアヌセー
貪欲 睡眠 これはもう日本訳のテキストの意味をそのまま入れたんですけど
突然この冬眠中の貪欲が現れてくる可能性あります
あるいはバヴァラーガーアヌセー
存在 生きていきたい 死にたくはないという欲望が
もう冬眠しています 次にパティガーアヌセー
この怒りですね 瞋恚ですね
これも冬眠中にあります
それからマーナ マーナというのは慢の睡眠ですけど
マーナっていうのは この自分がいるということで
他人と比べるんですよ
私と他人という いつでも私と他
で いつでも比較している
俺が偉い 偉い 偉いと思っているわけじゃないんですよ
その能力だけは寝ている
冬眠中なんですよ 何かに触れると上がってくるんです
5番目はディッターアヌセー
見解の睡眠ですね 説明は前しました
見解は 人間は性格的にどんな教えに
どんな宗教に どんな政党にね
行くかというね 冬眠していますよ
その傾向性に 適切なものに出会ったらもう活動するんです
だから冬眠中の煩悩がいい条件に出会ったら活動すると
活動するときはもう遅いんですよ
我々瞑想しながら何を制御管理しているのか
この活動中の煩悩なんですよ
潰すならば 冬眠中の煩悩を潰さなくちゃいけないんですよ
で  6番目はヴィチキッチャーアヌセー
疑ということ 疑ということは
この 何でしょうかね 自分で判断しないし
もう理解しようともしない
そうかな まああんまり信じられ信じ難いとかね
信じられませんとかね
そうやって平気でも何でも疑ってみる
まあなんか怠けみたいなもんなんですよ
だから 知るためには努力しないと
調べないと研究しないと反論しないと比較しないと
大変ですよ 知る世界は
軽々何でも疑問 疑問に思っちゃえばね
そんなこと言ったっても
誰が知ったもんかとかね
一見なんか頭が良さそうに見えるんだけど
本当はそうじゃないんです
あるいは人が これはいくら言ってもなかなか納得いかない
どうしても疑問があるよという場合は
本人が頑張ってるんですよ
理解しようと それは疑いに入りません
いきなり信じ込むことは無知なんですよ
だから理性的な疑を持たないと人間は成長しません
疑を持ったということは責任があるんですよ
これはどうしてもわからないんだというね
どうしても納得いかないんだと
ということはあったら
自分には責任があるんですね
研究して 調べて 事実を確かめるという
それは煩悩じゃないんです
こちらで煩悩というのは
ただ単にそんなこと言ってもね
誰が知ってるもんかね
本当かなとかね どうかなとかね
全部なあで終わっちゃうんですね
考え方も喋り方も それはヴィチキチャーヌ性
で 仏教的な定義っていうのははっきりしています
ものは停止しない ものは存在もしない
すべて無常で流動的で瞬間的な一時的な存在なんですよ
舞台の上にある役者の演技みたいな
そのコマだけのことで
次のコマは別なんです
すべてが それも原因によって一時的に成り立つんです
それが知らない限りは疑いがあるんです
どうしても現れますよ
神がいると言ったっても
そうかなと首をかしげるなるし
絶対いないさと言っちゃうと
本当かな そんなこと言ってもなんかあるんじゃないかなという疑いあるんですよ
あなたには霊魂魂があるんだぞと
そんなこと言っても本当にあるのかという疑い
まるっきりない ないと言ったってもとかね
だからこの因果法則がわからない限りは
もう世の中というのは疑いだらけなんです
何一つの結論がないんです
それは仏教の本物の定義なんです
そこまでいかなくても
ただ私の説明でも十分だと思います
7番目はアヴィッジャーヌ性
無明という睡眠 無明っていうのは心の能力のなささなんですよ
あるという情報がどんとぶつけたら目が覚めて
あ あるんだということだけで
でないと心は弱くて機能しない状態が無明なんです
なんだ 普通の煩悩ではないかと思われるでしょう
しかし 機能的に差があります
この 7つ聞いたら 仏教を勉強している方々
なんだこれは まあただ普通の煩悩でしょうと
なんで潜在煩悩 冬眠中煩悩と言うんでしょうかと
それは機能で言ってるんですね
はっきりと義がある時は表面的だからアヌセではありません
しかし しょっちゅうアヌセが現れるんだから
何か種があるはずなんです
だからそれも頻度でチェックすればね
我々はしょっちゅう欲出しているのか
で 存在欲でやっているのか
怒りでいるのかどうかね
頻度を見ると  24時間くらいチェックしてみて
そうすると潜在煩悩のこともおそらくこんなものじゃないかなと
理解はできます これは隠れた
種です 条件が揃ったら表面化して普通の煩悩になる
で 隠れている種の状態
例えば怒りの種がない人が
まあよっぽど怒ることに出会わない限りは
そう簡単には怒れませんね
そういう人々 皆様経験あると思いますよ
もうそう滅多に怒らない人とかね
なかなか別に何言われたっても別に平気で怒らないでいるとかね
怒らせるのは大変難しい人々はいるんですよ
あるいはもう何をしなくても怒っている人々もいるでしょうに
だからそこを見ると まあ似ているんじゃないかなと
この潜在的な冬眠煩悩も
普通の人はなぜ突然に殺す殺しをしたり
他の犯罪をしたりするのですか？とかね
よくマスコミで話題にするテーマでしょうね
みんな本当にいい人でしたけどとかね
わからないねとかね 精神分析しなくちゃいけない
精神分析だとそんなわかるわけないでしょうに
あの学校の先生たち殺した子供は
まあもう調べれば分かりそうと思って
子供のコンピューターやらね
まあ日記やら全部持っていったところで何もないんですね
ただの普通の子供なんですね
ごく普通の子供の世界で
変なところ一つもない
頑張らなくちゃとかね
どんな子供でも頑張らなくちゃと書くんだけど
頑張りはしませんしね
まあそんなのはもう で
わからないんですよ やっぱり冬眠中の煩悩が突然目を出したんです
で 人殺しやになっちゃったんです
不確定な様々な環境に遭遇した時
どのように反応するでしょうかと
我々は知ってますかと
我々は知らないでしょう
我々はこれからいろんなことに出会うでしょうね
その時 欲出すか 怒り出すか
舞い上がるか 楽しむか
落ち込むかわからないでしょうに
自分がどういうふうな自分の種の 7つの種がね
どんなふうに機能しているのかというのはわからない
7つあることはあるんですよ ８
はないんです  7つだからね
で もう種って言ったっても
種類によって早く芽が出るものとかね
なかなか芽が出ないもの
時間かかるものとあると同じく
我々も日常生活の中でいろんなものに遭遇する
その時どんな反応を起こすかということは自分でもわからない
だからこれから私は人を殺すか
何か他の犯罪するかとか
そんな知ったものじゃないんです
しかし この潜在煩悩を読み取れるならば
先に言えるんですよ この人はもうそろそろ人を殺すでしょうと
すごいかわいくて真面目で大人しくいたっても
まあそろそろやるでしょうと
なんとか それがブッダにしか一応わからないんですよ
しかし 睡眠中の種子を知っているならば推測できます
もし我々は睡眠中の種を知ってるんだったら
明日私はどんな人間になるでしょうかというぐらいなんとかはわかります
アーサイの働きは個人によって違います
これも個人によって個人差があります
怒りの種が簡単に芽が出るものもいるし
欲の種が簡単に出る人もいるし
義の種が出る人もいるしね
無知の種が無明の種が出る人もいるし
存在欲の種がもう簡単に芽が出る人々もいます
あの際の働きをね あのそうですけど
働きは個人により違いますと
これ多重構成なんですね
そうすると一応それで説明は終わりますけど
で 認識世界 心の我々知っているのはこれだけ
だけど少々勉強すると意識できる感情もあります
それは貪瞋痴 不貪不瞋不痴というね
みんなこの善悪のことを知ってるです
それなりにこれが悪い
嘘言っちゃあかんとかね
一般人も言うでしょうに
それは意識できるところで意識世界なんですね
その下にアーサガがあるんですよ
漏れる煩悩 下から上から下から漏れる
こちら辺で働き出します
働き出してこちらに影響を与えます
こちらに影響を与えます
その浅いの下に浅いの下に浅いがあるんですよ
これが同じものを表面になる場合もあるし
まるっきり違う もこちら怒りあるのにこの世界で優しい人間ふりまっちゃう場合もあります
こちらすごい欲があるのに
こちらで一生懸命ボランティアする場合もあります
これ 浅いの世界 それで一番裏に潜在煩悩の種があるんですね
とにかくここから芽が出るんですよ
こちらに芽が出て まるっきり逆に変化するかわからない
で ここら辺でまた変わって
ここら辺でまた変わって表面になるんですね
だからここから下は人格を構成する無意識領域ですね
これは個人にはわからない世界
あー浅は浅い あの性レベルは個人にわからない
だからこの今日は癖の話ですけど
癖はこちらで構成するんです
合成するんです この辺で
こちらのものは癖じゃないんです
わざとやってるんだから
忘年会でわざとだらしない形して遊ぶっていうことは癖じゃないんです
みんな楽しませてやるぞと
でもいくら言っても服装はだらしない
どう頑張ってもできない人の場合は
下からそうやらせているんです
それが癖なんです それからここ
この二表二層は自外世界の世界ですね
この二つは だからあの人がね
我が思う故に我がいると言ったのはこれだけの話なんです
これもしょっちゅう変わりますけどね
これは知らない そこで影響の流れ
外からの情報がずっと入って
あの性まで行って あの性が成長するんです
例えば いろんな人を見ると
あの人すごい優しくかっこしているな
かっこいいな 俺も優しく振る舞おうと思っちゃうんです
そうすると あーあー性の世界でしょ
私もそっちを怒ってますけど
俺はあかん 別に怒りがなくしたわけじゃなくて
怒りがあるにも関わらず
あの人の真似をして優しい人間を振りまったりする
そうやって外から情報が入っても
外から情報が入るとこれが変わる
これが変わる これも変わる
あー性も変わる あの性も変わる
それから影響の流れ 上にもあります
こちらから影響を与えて
あー性が変わる あー性から影響を受けてあーさが変わる
あー沢から影響を受けて
貪瞋痴が不貪不瞋痴がなんとか現れてきて
それで考えたりする 行動したりする
癖はここら辺なんですね
ここら辺は我々の普通の生き方なんです
こういう流れで癖が現れてくるんです
だからこの多重構造だからわからないんですね
多重構造といっても同じ煩悩なんですよ
機能的にこうやって 構想になるんです
これが正しく理解できなかった人々は唯識論というものを作ったんです
勉強してない そこら辺見つけてないでしょ
かなり見つけにくいところなんです
経典の中でも で なぜ癖がつくのかという別なタイトルですね
原因は 2つです  1 煩悩
感情 執着性 感情の執着性と書いた方がいいかなと思いますけどね
感情の執着性ってインパクトなんですね
説明あります 生きている上で
楽しみ 感動 怒り 嫉妬などの感情が現れて
心にインパクトを与えるんですよ
それで癖になっちゃうんです
よく平気で言うでしょうね
癖になりそうと その意味なんですよ
あまりにも感動してしまったんですよ
心にインパクトを与えちゃったんですよ
だから これは癖になりそうと平気で言うんです
その通りなんです だから煩悩ですよ
原因は で それが忘れがたいものになって簡単に思い出す
心で幻想化する だから何か美味しいものを食べちゃって
すっごく気に入ってしまったら
感動してしまったら 後からもそれを思ったりする
自分でも真似事をしようともする
それでやがて癖になってしまうんですね
だから我々はいつでも癖作ってるんです
癖が変わらないものじゃないんです
過去生から持ってきたんだからではないんです
毎日癖 新しい癖を作っている場合があるんですよ
大体子供は赤ちゃんなんかは何の癖あるのかわからないでしょうね
まあ生まれつき持ってくる癖もあるんだけど
それから大きくなる過程で新しい癖がいっぱいつくんですよ
例えばゲームに依存するんでしょ
子供たちは すごい病気なんですけど
あれはもう新しい現代病で
もう最近できた癖なんですね
しかし 遊びたいということは
昔のからも子供たち どんな生命の子供にもあるんです
動物の子供も遊ぶんです
それが遊ぶものは成長するために刺激を与えなくちゃいけないだからなんです
だから昔の子供たちは手作りのおもちゃで
もうかなり自分で頑張って遊んでいたんです
それでかなり成長したんですよし
人格もできたし 病気にならなかったんです
今は子供に何もさせない
親切な大人が全部おもちゃ作って
ゲーム作って 高い値段で売る
それで子供たちは人格構成も何もできなくて
犯罪者で終わるんです
それで大人たちがまた涙流しながら
もうなんで現代子供たちはこんな風になるんでしょうかとかね
学力低下はどうしようかとかね
もっとゲーム作ろうという結果になるんです
だから 自我 自分の悪さに気づかないということで
どんどん悪循環で悪化していくんです
それはこういう原因やというのは仏教だけだから
一番嫌われるんですね
それで 2番目の癖の原因は繰り返すこと
同じことを繰り返しちゃうと
もう好きになっちゃうんです
美味しくない食べ物でも
何回何回食べてみると
何のこともないんです
もう美味しく感じるんです
で 同じことを繰り返すと
刷り込みが深くなってしまいます
それで慣れたもんになるんです
動物の調教にも人間の教育にもこの法則を使うのです
教育の場合ではその法則なんですね
動物でも同じことを繰り返しちゃうと
それから癖になっちゃってやってくれるんですよ
動物の芸っていうのは癖なんです
別に考えてやってるわけじゃないんです
イルカであろうが犬であろうか
もう繰り返して繰り返してやらせて
そうするともう笛を鳴らしたり
なんとか見せたりしちゃうと
その決まってる反応をするんです
もう癖なんです で 私たちも勉強するということは繰り返すことでしょ
お釈迦様も同じことをおっしゃるんですよ
例えば まあ頭が良くなりたいとかなんとかというならば
財界としてね 成功したいというならばね
よく勉強しなさいと よく勉強するということは
まず先生が言うことは真剣真面目に聞く
わからないところは質問して
さらに納得いくまでわかってもらう
それから繰り返し訓練する
ということで しっかり勉強できますよ
ある宿題をすることなんですね
勉強したということもある一定の癖なんですよ
医学をやったということは
医学的な癖がついちゃったんでしょうし
生物学やる人々は生物学的な癖がついているでしょうし
だからバカの壁という考え方を出しちゃったの
養老先生にしたっても偉い曲者なんですよ
だからすごい学者でしょうに
ものすごいある分野で研究しているんだから
いつでもまあゾウムシやら虫殺したり
昆虫殺したりして もうどうでそちらに興味あるんですよ
そこで一般の日本人には
あんた方はもう毛虫見たっても
もう見ないでしょう 見えないでしょうと
五百円玉が落ちていたらすぐ目が行くでしょうとかね
それがバカの壁やと言ったっても
本人もどうったことはないんですけどね
で 癖がついちゃって だから五百円玉に目が行くんですけど
ゾウムシに目が行かない人は
まあその癖がついているんです
金には価値があるんだと
それだけのことで あの先生には
まあ虫に面白い世界があるんだと
その癖がついているんです
だから勉強した 学問した
知識を得たということは
ある癖がついたっていうこと
別に悪いことじゃないんですよ
何かの癖がつくことなんです
だから私は日本語を喋ってるし
でも時々自分でこれ日本語おかしいんじゃないかと
自分喋ってる日本語は
と気づいちゃうんですよ
なんでおかしいなと考えちゃうと
この単語の並び替えと言葉のシンタックスの使い方
日本語的じゃないんですね
あれ これどこからどうなったか分からなくなっちゃうんだから
大体何するのかで そのまま英訳するんですね
だったら立派な英語の文章なんですね
これ そのまま英語を日本語にしたっても日本語になりませんだけど
いつでもやってるわけではないんだけど
時々日本語に引っかかった時は
あれ なんで日本語に引っかかったのかというと
英訳してみるんです そしたら
やっぱりこれは英語の癖やと
で 最初に結論出してしゃべるでしょ
日本人にはちんぷんかんぷんの結論出しちゃうと
だって yes no しない世界でしょうに
もう曖昧でありがたいいい
かっこいいやと ほんで最初から私は yes no と判断してしまっちゃって
しゃべるとわからないね
あなた言ってることはと
だから嘘をつくのはね
どうかなね どうかなと思いますけどと言っちゃえばわかるんですよ
どうかなと思いますけどねとかね
嘘をつくなよ それが悪い
何を言うんでしょう この人はと
だからそれぞれ の癖なんです
だから私にはいくら頑張っても曖昧で中途半端ではしゃべれません
ビシビシって それ癖なんです
それ自分が勉強した癖なんです
はい そういう 2つの原因で癖がつく
感情的になるか繰り返すかと
例えば 何か勉強嫌いだったら
数学は嫌いだったら 数学でふざけて遊んじゃえばいいんですよ
そうすると遊び事は気持ちいいんだから
数学も好きになってできるようになるんですね
ある日本の有名な数学者が
大学の先生がね そういうやり方でやってるんですけど
名前忘れちゃったんですけど
すごいだらしない服装を着ている
秋山先生 ものすごい立派な数学者なんですよ
でも そこら辺にいるもういい加減な不良社のおじさんの形の格好なんですね
喋る時でも何でもふざけていて
だからって 本人は決してふざけてる人物ではありませんよ
しっかりした教授で で
彼がなんでそういうことをやるのか
ものすごいもうガリガリ神経で数学の葬式書いたり書いたりしたらみんな嫌いなんだからね
そんなこと面白くないんだと
だからものすごく面白い
ふざけてやると数学は好きになる
その先生は学校にでもどこでもちょっとした授業をやっちゃうと
みんなすごい喜んで わーわーとわいわいと参加するし
言ってることは理解もする
だから このそうやって癖がつかなくちゃいけない
この 2つの原因で たった 2つ
好きになるか繰り返すか
どれだけなんです 癖直せるのかと
今までの説明で これは大変難しいことだと理解できる
今まで説明っていうのは
多重構想の絶対気がつかない心の働きがあるんだから
しかし直せるから直せないといけないからこそ
釈尊がその真理を明かされているのです
癖だからといって言い訳になりません
悪い癖を直さなくちゃいけない
だからお釈迦様はあの難しい心の働きを明確に説明しているんです
癖だからといって悪いことをしちゃうと地獄に落ちますよ
癖は言い訳になりません
私はもう習慣になったんだから人を殺してますよと
だから閻魔様 私を許してくださいと言ったってもね
習慣であろうか 突然人を殺したであろうと
殺した人殺しは人殺しだからね
だから癖は危ない 悪い癖は直さなくちゃいけない
だから悪い癖 良い癖ありますよ
だけど 勉強することは良い癖
知識を発達することは良い癖
一切は無常だから 因縁により起こるものだから直せるんです
固定したもの何もないんだから
変わらないもの何もないんだからね
そんな癖なんかは簡単に直せます
簡単ではないんだけど
直せるんです で 直せる方法
まずこれやるんです 悪い癖を良い癖に入れ替える
自分の悪い癖をもうできるだけ発見して
良い癖に入れ替える そのために仏教では善行為しなさいと言ってますよ
十悪がありまして 十善があるんだと
まあ殺したいということは
どんな人間にもある本能的な癖なんですよ
潰したい 殺したいと それで私は絶対殺しませんよと
そこを癖にするんです
生命は殺さないで ものすごく自分を気をつける
それで 1年  2年  3年  4年ぐらい殺生しないことを守ると
なんのことうまく自然に殺せない人間になるんです
嘘を言うのは つくのはもう人間の本能ですよ
生命の動物の嘘をつくんだから
で それでいや 嘘をつかないということに挑戦する
この挑戦が繰り返していくと直してしまいます
それを繰り返すんです
たった 1日だけ戒律を守っても
いい人間になりませんよ 1
日だけ嘘をつかないんだぞと思ってもね
それでは足らん 繰り返さないと
良い行為に対しても 喜び
充実感 満足感を感じることにインパクト刷り込みを与えるというか
文章はちょっと間違いですけどね
それで私は嘘をつかない
あるいは私は殺生しないということにするでしょうに
それがもうかっこいいやと
私なりに まあ結構なかなかいいんじゃないかと
捨てたもんじゃないんだと
そういうふうに喜びを感じた方がいいんです
人間として自分がもうもうほとんど嘘をついてないんだと
殺生なんかはしてないんだと
遊びにでも釣りなんかは絶対しないんだと
で 自分が良い癖をつくる
つく良い癖を習うことに喜びを感じる
それが充実感を感じる
そうすると刷り込み刷り込みになるんです
いい人間になったんだから
まただらしない人間にはもうなりたくないんだと
常に心の働きぶりを観察する
それからいつでも自分の心は今
今の状況はどんな状況かなとデータ更新しなくちゃいけないんですよ
今怒ってるんだと 今落ち込んでいるんだと
今の状態 それすごく必要なんです
この 2つでないと完璧になりません
また 癖も癖ものということで
煩悩が消えたら これ別な考え方なんです
悟りを開いたら癖もなくなるのではないかと
今までの説明で理解しているでしょう
だって全部煩悩でしょ？同じ煩悩でしょ
たとえ潜在煩悩であろうか
阿僧祇であろうか 阿努僧祇であろうか
阿娑婆であろうか もう同じ煩悩なんです
貪瞋痴であろうか 同じもの
だったら悟るということは煩悩をなくすことだから
あの前 いっぱい色で描いたものはもう真っ白くなることだからね
あ 癖もないと思うでしょう
違いますね これも俗世間で癖というのは体の行為と言語の使い方なんですよ
我々は偉そうに癖 癖というのは
このちょっと体のちょっとしたこと
ちょっとした動き 動き
この言葉使い方 みんなみんな自分の日本語持ってますよ
どんな人でも しゃべる言語にも癖がつくんですよ
それであれで あんた変なことを言ってるんではないかとかね
言うかもしれませんだけど
人間考える癖っていうのは
その程度 体の動きか 言語の癖か
仏教はそれを全然気にしない
歩き方ちょっと変とかね
寝方がちょっと変とかね
食べ方がちょっとおかしいとかね
全然気にしない しゃべる言語はちょっとおかしいとかね
時々失礼な動詞使ったりする場合もありますね
癖になっていて それ使っちゃうとかね
そんなのは仏教では気にしない
例えば私にしても あいつこいつっていうのは単語すごく気に入ってるんです
これは普通はあんまり使ってはいけない単語であることは知ってますが
自分にとってはすごい気分がいいんで使っちゃうと
あいつはねとかね だから好きになってるんだから
スイスイ使っちゃうんですよ
別に嫌な気持ちで使ってるわけじゃなくて
本人が喜んでるだけふざけてるだけの話なんです
でもその話聞いたら 何人か私に注意
そんなことを使ってはいけません
とんでもないんだと もっと品のある言葉を喋らなくちゃいけないんではないかとかね
あ そうということで 別に気にしない
まあそんな癖ぐらいはどうでもいいんじゃないかなと
だから私は喋る時も 私の日本語の癖やらね
そういうところばっかり気にして言ってる内容はまるっきりもうもう無関心
跳ね返っていくでしょうに
それは皆様の癖なんです
損しますけどね 私の癖で私は損したことはないんです
それは覚えておいてくださいね
歩き方おかしいとかね
座り方おかしいとかね
部屋は全然整理整頓しないんだと
こんな悪い癖とかね なんだこれとかね
そんなのはどうでもいいんです
ただ 体の行為と言語の行為だからね
で 心の癖が本当の問題ですよ
本当の問題は心の癖なんです
今日のお話も全部心の癖についてなんです
体と言語の癖に 心の状態
癖は心の状態より善になったり悪になったりする
例えば言語がおかしいと言っても
善でも悪でもないんですよ
面白がって言ってるんだったら
しかし 気分はそうなっちゃうと
例えばあいつっていう言葉は
わざと失礼 失礼な態度で言っちゃうと
これはもう悪なんです
子供が可愛いあまりにこいつは殺してやりたいというのは
決して乱暴な言葉じゃないんですよ
言葉殺してやりたい とんでもない言語でしょうに
でも何のこともないんですよ
しかし 子供のこと嫌で憎しんで
こいつは殺してやるという人で恐ろしいんですよ
だから言語の癖はどうでもいいんですよ
心の状態が大事なんです
だからそこを気をつけてほしいんですね
心は善であるならば 体と言語の癖は問題になりません
だから 気持ちとして君は可愛いという気持ちでお前を殺してやりますと言っても
それは決して悪口でも不善行為でもありません
えーと 悟り開いた方の心は
善も悪も乗り越えていて
無色透明なのです 悟り開いたら善も悪もない
無色透明なんです 心が
そうすると癖がないのかと
しかし 悟っても癖が残るのです
これが問題 心はもう無色透明になったんだけど
癖が残るんですよ 言語の癖と体の癖が残るんです
俗世間は何を言っても
その癖は善でも悪でもありません
例えば悟った人に対して
あの人は性格が悪いんだとかね
食べ方が良くないんだとかね
いろいろ言ってもどうったことはない
例えば 知恵の第一人者っていうのは
お釈迦様の右腕 サーリプッタ尊者でしょうね
癖があるんですよ それでも
一つは結構甘党なんです
で これがあの日本ですごい立派な学者でいて亡くなったこの中村元先生
もの巨大な学者でしたけどもね
これまた甘党なんですね
すごい性格が優しくて
ものすごい謙虚で ああ
知恵の人っていうのはえらい似ているんだと
私はそれ感心しましたけどね
で 世間で見るともう近寄りがたいすごい先生なんですけど
実際に話してみると まあ優しくて
ただの親父というおじいさんなんですよ
何も知らないおじいさんだなと
もう可愛くてたまらんですよ
それで我々はコーヒー飲んでると
この先生は何をやりとるのかというと
アイスクリームを食べるんです
全然似合わないんだけどね
甘党なんです これでサーリプッタ尊者も結構すごい
性格的にはものすごい謙虚で控えめでいるんだけど
まあおかしいになってくると
ちょっと手が出るんですよ
それで時々お腹を壊したりしたこともあるんです
ある沙弥にものすごくひどく非難されたこともあるんですよ
ある一回 このサーリプッタ尊者のお菓子の中でもある特別なお菓子がありまして
この蒸しパンみたいなものがあって
これはすごい好きなんですね
サーリプッタ尊者を尊敬している信者さんたちが
わざとこの甘い蒸しパンを作って
もうたくさん弟子たちがいるんだからね
サーリプッタ尊者のところ
子供たちはいっぱいいるんですね
持っていったんですね
みんなの分 それでみんなの分をあげて
サーリプッタ尊者もほんのちょっと一人分は別にたくさん召し上がるわけじゃないんだから
まあ召し上がって 一人の子供が托鉢に出ていたんです
サーリプッタさんだ すごい子供のことを心配するんだから
信者さんに一部 あの子は托鉢に出て行ったんだからね
置いておいてくださいと
だから本人から見れば本人の供物だから
子供食べたら楽しいだろうという考え方でしょうね
置いておいたんですよ
子供は帰ってくるのが遅いんです
子供といっても出家しているんです
で 待ってるは待ってるは待ってるはね
まあやっぱり午前中召し上がらなくちゃいけないし
来る気配はないんです
わからないしね もしかすると村でご飯食べて帰ってくる可能性もある
そうすると時間終わってるでしょうし
まあ大体早く帰りますけど
それで信者さんがあの子供の沙弥はまあちょっと遅くなるみたいんですよと
で 12時過ぎたら このもらったご飯は全部捨てるんです
冷蔵庫に入れておけば
まだ冷蔵庫がなかったし
捨てるようになっているんです
戒律上は そこでお坊さんたちに教えたものだから
信者さんがまた戻してもらうことはしません
ちょっと日本とは違います
日本でお釈迦様にお供えして
またあれ戻って全部食べちゃうんですね
あれ すごい 私は気持ち悪いんですけどね
一旦教えたものは食べません
ということで 信者さんたちがね
あの子は帰ってくる気配はないんだから
尊師召し上がったらいかがでしょうかと
で なんて捨てるでしょうしね
信者さんたちから見たら
一生懸命腕を振って作ったお菓子でしょうに
で サーリプッタそうだなということで
じゃあ食べようかなで召し上がったんですよ
だから余ってなかったらいい
私は自分の分は飯を食べましたから
まあ結構やというのが普通ですけど
あの家の第一人者はそこら辺では弱いんですね
召し上がったんですね
召し上がって終わってと子供は来るんですよ
サーリプッタさんとはすごく親だからね
結局は ちょっとどこかでああ
子供にお菓子食べさせた方がいいなという気持ちもある
もうないしね 一応子供に行ったんですね
今日はね すごくおいしいお菓子もらった
みんな食べて君の分も置いておいたよと
で 君が遅いんだから私は食べましたと
子供はすごい機嫌が悪くなっちゃったんです
だからなかなか美味しいものはね
もらわないし 托鉢でしょうしね
だからたまたま信者さんがね
まあサーリプッタ尊者に会った時はおごちそう作ってあげるし
だからそんな時は子供でもちょっとちゃんと作った料理食べたいでしょうね
だから子供はすごく嫌味ったんですよ
甘いもの 美味しいものだったらね
誰でも目がないんだから
すごくなんかサーリプッタ尊者ってすごい失礼な言葉なんですね
まあ子供の言葉だから
一応 それはね まあ美味しいんだから
誰でもね もう食べるでしょうとか嫌味言って
それにもうそれにサーリプッタ尊者がね
気づいて気づいたんじゃないんですけど
これはあかんと 自分が子供の頃からね
ものすごい贅沢の家の方なんですよ
そういうことで 自分が情けなくて
この癖を戒めようとしなかったと
今まで 今日限り食べませんと
きれさっぱり切っちゃったんです
お菓子はそれから召し上がらなかったんです
それは偉大なる人のやり方で
ほんのちょっとのことで
別にもうどうったことないといえばどうったことないんですけどね
サーリプッタ尊者はいいわけいくらでもあるでしょうね
だっていつ帰ってくるかわからないし
遅くなってきたら君が悪いんじゃないかと言えばいいんだけどね
やっぱり子供 たとえ子供でもそういうことを子供からでも言われたっていうことは
自分のこれは悪い癖やと
そのその日からは決して召し上がらなかったんです
そういうことで 偉大なるサーリプッタ尊者にも
まあちょこっとした癖っていうのはあったんですよ
偉大の方々の癖というのは
どちらかというと なんとなく可愛いんですが
一応はっきり記録されているのはそれほど可愛くない疑問になる癖なんですね
いろいろ戒律の本なんか読んでみると
いろんなこと出てきます
だから悟っても残りますよ
癖は それは心の癖じゃないんです
体と言語の癖なんです
だから悟った人の癖に文句言ってはいけない
罪になるんです いくらなんでも気をつけないと
心は清らかだからね  例えば失礼な単語でね
お前ってめとかね コラとか何とか言っていたっても
心はすごい悟っている
清らかな人だったらもうそれは癖やということで開き直るというかね
もう諦めないと 私も自分の長老がちょっと失礼な単語でみんなに喋るんだから
慣れてなかったんで 自分の家では 1
日目 2日目はもうかなりひどい言葉喋るなと
このお坊さんがと すごく違和感があったんですけど
でもちょっと一緒に長老と一緒にいると
これはものすごい もう国で稀なすごい人格者やと
国中みんなもう尊敬するし
政治家始めてもう毎日寺にもういつでもいろんな偉い方々来るんです
で ずっと一緒に生活してみると
ものすごい人格者で もうすごいんです
それで私は私たちのような人にできるだけすごい低い単語で呼び捨てで呼べる呼ぶことがすごく好きになっちゃったんです
お前とかなんとかというのは
これが好きで好きで なんで失礼な言葉を使うの？という気持ちがなくなっちゃったんです
だから私はもう長老亡くなる時でもずっとそばにいたんですけど
やっぱりいつでもああいう単語で
もうすっごい このもうそこら辺のもう不良者のガキを呼ぶような感じで私を呼ぶんですよ
もうすっごい喜びが湧いてくるんです
呼ばれると ものすごい自分のことはもう心配しているんだと
我々も互いの癖を差別意識で見てはならないんです
我々知っているのは心の癖じゃないんだから
体と言葉の癖だから それは決して差別意識で見てはいけない
放っておいてください
体の癖と言葉の癖っていうのは
では 癖がなくなった人はいないのか
悟った人の癖があるんだからね
一人だけいるんですよ
これは証覚者ですね サンマーサンブッダという釈尊のことなんです
すべて癖も消したのはたった釈尊だけなんです
釈尊は悟りを開いた時
無始なる過去からついてきたあらゆる癖も煩悩と一緒に滅したのです
それはお釈迦様の に 特別な智慧の一つなんです
それは特別な単語があります
今日書いてないんですけど
キレーサワーサナという
キレーサというのは煩悩で
煩悩は誰でもなくします
で 涅槃に入られます ワーサナっていうのは癖なんです
それまでなくなるんだと
ブッダの場合は 阿羅漢になった弟子には無害な癖は残っているんです
害な癖はなくなりますよ
煩悩と一緒に 怒りも憎しみも全部消えちゃいますけどね
しかし 言葉だけは何のこともないんだから
そんなのは残っちゃうんですね
ただちょっと走るとか
ある阿羅漢が他のお坊さんたちとどこかの村に行ったんですよ
みんなすごく下を見て丁寧にゆっくり歩くんです
そこで水たまりがあったんです
みんななんて丁寧にお坊さんたちが歩くことだと
みんな感動して見ているんです
そこで ちょっとお年のおじさんぐらいのお年の長老
過去のお坊さんなんですよ
このあるお坊さんが こういう道路で水たまりがあったんです
泥がね 別にアスファルト道路じゃないんだからね
それで他の前にいたもっと年上の長老たちが
それ何のことなく歩幅を変えることなく
水たまりに足を入れて泥の中をそのまま歩いていったんです
先に このお坊さんの番に来たら
何のことなくパチンと前に飛んだんです
軽々と それで見た人は
あのお坊さんはね まだまだね
できてないんだと ちょっと人裏でコソコソと
後ろに若いお坊さんたちはみんなちゃんと歩いたのに
泥の中に入って でもそんなこと言うなよと
どちらよりもこの人はすごく偉いんだと
阿羅漢だよ 阿羅漢ですけど
昔からなんなら水たまりぐらい何や
ということをね  やっちゃいます
それで私たち 悪になる
他人に迷惑になる癖をなくすように努力する
繰り返しめげずに良い習慣を習う
そうしなくちゃいけないんですよ
正しい人 真理の人 人格者を目標にして挑戦する
癖がなんとか良い方向になるんです
負けても負けても諦めない
そう簡単に癖が治りませんだからね
負けても負けても諦めないっていうことにしなくちゃいけないんです
良い人を目標にして まあ世の中で完璧な人っていうのはいないんだけど
ブッダ以外はね それでも自分なりに誰か誰かね
まあ人格者を目標にして
その人のいいところだけ真似ると
悪い癖のところはちょっと置いておくと
こういうやり方で我々は頑張らないといけないんです
他人に迷惑のない体の言語の癖をそれほど気にしない
私たちもその体と言語の癖っていうのは気にする必要はないんです
それも他人に迷惑ないならばなんです
自分の食べ方が他人に迷惑だったらやめた方がいいんですよ
例えば 日本では全然必要と思わないんですけど
この食べる時も音を立てる
我々の文化では これはものすごいだらしない
もう一緒にも食べたくないというぐらいなんで厳しい
やっぱり私は食べないんで
できるだけ一緒には もう音を立てるんだからね
どうかね なんかじっと鳥肌が
でもまあこれはまあいいんじゃない
この文化だからっていうことですぐ開き直れますけど
忙しい時はそこまではできないんですね
だからまあ それが迷惑どうかは私はわかりませんだけど
時々私たちのなんとなく癖が他人の迷惑になる場合があります
その場合は気をつけてやめた方がいいんです
そうでない限りは別に気にする必要はないんです
で ついでに言いますけど
いびきは癖じゃないんです
いびきはえらい迷惑なんですけどね
これはまあ病気というかね
治療した方がいいんですよ
なぜかいびきかく人にも眠れませんよ
深く だから睡眠不足になるんです
それから 他人から 他人にからかわれても落ち込んだりしないで一緒に笑ってあげる
自分の癖 人がなんかいじめたりからかったりしたって気にしないこと
一緒に笑っちゃえばいいんです
みんなそれで結構いじめられたとかなんとか言うでしょ
学校でとかね 他人の癖を批判しない
私たちは他人の癖も批判してはいけないんです
しかし 良い人間になる本業を決して忘れない
諦めない 自分の癖も気にしないんだけど
自分が人格的に良い人間にならなくちゃいけない
それが人間の本業な本職なんです
会社の仕事じゃないんです
その本職は決して忘れてはいけないんです
大体こんな程度やと思いますけど
で 終わりです では まあ一応話はそこで終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます